I thought it would be helpful to talk a
little bit about the world economic
forum and uh what it stands for what its
goals are and kind of talk about mle's
Presence at that conference in Davos um
mala's introduction was given by none
other than our favorite super vesque
German Professor CLA Schwab founder of
the WF let's hear a little bit of uh
Schwab's
introduction it's for me a great great
honor to welcome Javier M as you know a
freely elected president of Argentina I
think you sometimes people would say
with more radical methods but you
introduce a new spirit to
Argentina making
Argentina much more related to free
enterprise to entrepreneurial
activities also to bring Argentina back
to the rule of law so we have a very
extraordinary person among us today and
of course we are all eager uh to listen
to you and again a very cordial Welcome
to the World economic
for all right so generally pretty
cordial mle is a he's radical but he's
bringing markets and the rule of law to
Argentina so maybe not all that bad the
WF is not contrary to some of the
theories out there some sort of you know
communist organization they're not
reflexively hostile to markets they just
in my view uh look at them as tools to
achieve certain social ends because
they're corporatists um and I have to
imagine you know having watched the
speech that he was not expecting what
happened next uh because we'll see soon
that Malay goes directly for the jugular
at of what the WF is actually all about
um or or maybe he doesn't just he just
doesn't care he he's 85 years old maybe
you know just want to YOLO spice things
up see what happens any thoughts of Liz
or Marcos about just kind of the WF CL
Schwab Davos I mean they're sort of
cringe technocratic Central planners um
so I have to believe that with the
amount of control they exert over the
rest of us surely they exerted lots of
control over preting the speeches which
makes me think that Malay went off
script a little bit um I don't know you
know whether or not that's true there's
not really any indication as to what
happened but that's sort of the only
explanation I can come up with that
explains how Malay got so delightfully
fiery uh in his speech in a way that is
sort of an indictment of some of the
things CLA Schwab stands
for what about you Marcos does the WF
like what is it what does it mean to you
if anything as someone who's living
through the economic turmoil in
Argentina um it doesn't really mean much
to me personally um but here in
Argentina there was a lot of expectation
about mle's speech particularly because
um of the of the idea that it could
mirror the speech that uh former
president mree gave in 2016 when he took
office when he yeah he he had just taken
office like one month prior just like
mle uh and back then this was like like
the reintroduction of Argentina into the
world stage right into the world of free
enterprise and so there was some
expectation as to um whether mle would
mirror that speech or or whether he
would go um offs script as Li said
although it I mean we'll talk about the
speech later but the speech itself is
not that different from the speech that
we as argentines have been hearing um
consistently from laay in the past years
U it's remarkably similar to um lectures
that he has given out loud to whoever
would listen um in different cities in
the country I was actually part of one
of them um in my hometown Marv Plata in
the summer of I think it was 2023 last
year um he he was just touring the
country you know and lecturing about
economics and freedom um and and some of
the contents of those lectures were
remarkably similar to the speech that we
saw at Davos so to what degree did this
actually mirror mri's
speech well
um I I would say that it did in that uh
they both favored uh free enterprise and
freedom in in you know on paper uh but
mle went after uh the the W um wef uh
scores values or not core values but
many of the interests that they have
taken in in past years uh in a way that
M did not I mean makri was all for you
know um fighting climate change and and
the progressive agenda in terms of uh
civil liberties uh whereas mle was
clearly uh like he he opposed all of
that he was clearly against all of that
so and he was much more radical in
arguing in favor of capitalism because
moer speech um resembled you know this
idea of Claus schw and others that um
capitalism is at the service of
something else you know that we value
capitalism because of the because it is
a means uh to to a different end whereas
mle argued in in my view at least that
capitalism is is good in itself because
it allows us to do whatever we want with
them which is not I think uh what the
world economic Forum stands for so in
that regard it did not mirror marro
speech there were similarities the
similarities but um I think this this
was a much more radical speech which is
what I would expect uh from a
Libertarian uh and Anar capitalist
president yeah and that's why I think
it's it is important going into this to
understand uh the the values of the WF
and and to not get distracted by some of
the strange uh theories about the WF and
I I'll I'll not so humbly recommend uh
one of my previous videos on this called
uh forget the great reset Embrace The
Great Escape that I I that kind of lays
out what the WF is actually all about um
which is not uh necessarily A like
nefarious um agenda to turn us all into
like transhuman AIS or something like
that but more so a kind of
manag a kind of managed version of
capitalism that has become known as
stakeholder capitalism where you uh in
you put aside kind of the previous like
Milton fredman conception of capitalism
as just delivering value to the
shareholders of a company to expanding
the Mandate of a company to deliver uh
to so-called stakeholders which could be
um environmentalist groups or labor
groups or any other kind of interest
group that you could come up with here
it it domestically Elizabeth Warren has
been one of the outspoken proponents of
this she's uh proposed you know I think
40% worker ownership or worker
representation on corporate boards in
California there's been attempts to kind
of rebalance what a what a corporate
board looks like and so that's why I
ultimately describe them as corporatist
and I think in kind of the the furthest
the the most uh extreme
uh instantiation or examp example of
like where where this heads would be
China where they actually put government
uh you know party officials on the
corporate boards so the stakeholder is
actually the government itself and that
gets into you know outright fascism so
can lead to really bad places China has
like the opposite of separation of state
and business it's all disturbingly
intermal in a way that I think a lot of
Western audiences just totally uh
misunderstand and uh in the at the 2022
Davos conference um xiin ping was the
kind of keynote speaker who kicked off
the conference and uh CLA gave him a
fairly glowing introduction there as
well which I I found kind of disturbing
but um before we move into mle's speech
uh let's play one more clip just to get
now that I think we've laid out a little
bit of of what the WF is about and what
Davos is about um CLA Schwab actually is
on the record uh with his opinion about
Libertarians and where
libertarianism fits into the New World
Order uh so let's uh roll that clip from
the 2017 World Government Summit in
Dubai we are at historical Crossroads we
Face a
backlash of millions of of people
particularly in the west who feels that
globalization is not working fixing the
present system is not
enough now there is of
course a
anti-stem which is
called
libertarianism which means to tear down
everything which
creates some kind of
influence of government into private
lives it's Dem manling the system and we
see certain elements of this now in the
new US Administration if we want to go
forward we need a completely new
thinking we have to integrate into our
future
policymaking is the
notion of
multistakeholder concept the big
challenges which we have cannot be
solved by governments alone but they
cannot be solved by business or Civil
Society alone we need new ways of
cooperation of very flexible cooperation
I wish you a very
good World Government Summit thank
[Music]
you okay so yeah new flexible ways of
cooperation uh between public and
private that's that's kind what I was
alluding to earlier and then you know
his assertion that Libertarians are
anti- system which you know we are yeah
we are anti your system the one you're
selling to a bunch of monarchs in the
UAE uh that leads you to open your
conferences with ODS to the wisdom of
xiin ping I I could not imagine a better
endorsement honestly but um you know we
again want to be really clear about what
the WF is and isn't um and you know even
even CLA uh Schwab uh has acknowledged
you know these these changes in that
these technological changes uh that have
driven political changes and made it
much harder
to have top- down control so he does at
times talk about the need for
subsidiarity the the need to uh have you
know more localized versions of control
and uh it he's he's not really at this
point advocating for some sort of One
World Government but more so that uh
local and National governments kind of
come in under the WF umbrella and kind
of we we have this common view of of
governance and these sort of common uh
tools and and consensus to kind of
manage the future uh but uh I just want
to open the floor to both of you for any
additional reactions to K Claus's view
of
libertarianism um I have a lot of
disdain for K Claus swabs description of
libertarianism I think first of all
Libertarians exist on this massive
glorious Spectrum there's obviously
rothbardian ancap types who very much
hate the state and do want to smash the
system uh in a very major way there are
also I think on the other side of the
spectrum a bunch of Libertarians who
look at the current system which
involves an awful lot of crony
capitalism and subsidies do out to uh
various companies that are sort of in
these bidding wars for contracts with
the government and they look at that and
they say why is it that anytime um
government sort of taints everything
that it touches uh you know anytime we
look at a project either done in Co
collaboration with a government or by a
government agency itself we see it
completed um you know two years later
than they had anticipated and massively
over budget in any other sector that
would be totally uh unex acceptable and
so a lot of Libertarians look at the
State of Affairs at present and say well
government like look at the results
government is not in many cases
delivering to nearly the degree that
they say they will and to us that
indicates that we need to privatize more
things and allow markets to um you know
conduct more affairs than the government
the thing is Libertarians I think are so
frequently portrayed as these like naive
people who think that absolutely
everything will be perfectly solved once
we get the government out of the way and
I think Libertarians actually frequently
realize that there will be short-term
pain points in the same way that I think
Malay is sort of setting Argentina up
for realizing that that is what will
happen in order to get inflation under
control in the short term there will be
massive unemployment there will continue
to be people living you know 40% of the
country below the poverty line right
like that is not going away tomorrow but
he will move things in the right
direction and will pursue a means of
getting inflation under control and I
think Libertarians that's the thing that
people really miss so I think clab is
totally misrepresenting what
Libertarians stand for hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcatcher
see you next week